what is up guys my name is jonah welcome
to episode 18.5 or express episode three
at least i think it's episode three
um yeah we'll we'll go for we'll go with
three for now
um of three game programming in java and
uh this is like another express episode
it's christmas right now it is the 25th
it's 8 p.m you can see right over here
um
although you know that's in australia of
course different time zones in the world
it might not even be christmas
somewhere in the world where at least
this episode probably will be there um
because christmas is wrapping up and it
has been uh it has been raining all day
um if we check out the uh the the radar
of the the weather radar of melbourne
then you can see that uh
the rains just passed all right look at
that like this that's insane
um i'm right i'm like right over here
nist and kilda so
that's just a bit lower elston work so
that's just completely
that's just completely passed and yeah
it's just been raining all day and we've
got so much rain today we've got more
rain than like
the past three months honestly today so
it was amazing
uh but yeah i just wanted to show that
to you guys and um today
what we're going to do you'll probably
tell this by the title because i'll
put it up in the title um we've covered
basically two ways of exporting we've
covered exporting to run as a runnable
jar file we've covered exporting
to run as an applet in a web browser
and um i'm still sick by the way i spent
the whole day
at home today didn't go anywhere but uh
that's okay um
yeah so we've covered um we've covered
exporting
as an applet we've covered exporting as
a runnable jar
but one thing that people have been
requesting um is exporting as a
as an executable file as an exa as a
windows.exe file
now i don't know why you would want to
export as this um
there are a few reasons but like usually
runnable jar works fine but um if you
just want to
basically make sure that people can run
it on a windows computer
uh without having to you know right
click go open with the java application
thing if um the java runtime environment
if
their default program isn't the java
runtime environment then of course the
dot exe is the easiest way to do so so
we're going to cover how to basically
export it out of eclipse as a dot exe um
well we can't
basically we have to use another program
but i'll get into that in a sec alrighty
okay let's get started so uh at the
moment we've sort of got like this thing
i don't
really want it at the moment i don't
really like what it's where it's at
at the moment because um well basically
you know it's just like a
it's not we can't really play this game
at the moment so let's just go back and
fix what we
did last uh last
uh episode um we're going to
render if we're going to screen actually
first let's just comment out
uh the walls so that we lose the walls
and uh get our frame right back and
hmm and the other thing we want to do is
if we go on render.3d
i always see i always say render.3d i
don't know what it is
freaking dot java oh so annoying okay
we'll set this to game dot uh what is it
game dot
controls dot uh
is it x what is it no it's that isn't it
i don't remember i think it's
yes it would be said um and is that and
our mouse we need to rotate we need to
get rotation back um and i think that
yep that's everything working correctly
awesome um and running exceptionally
fast
okay so we're basically ready to export
now um i just didn't want to export the
wall
like thing because you couldn't really
play that and play around with that so
yeah i changed it back to what it was
originally okay so
we're gonna hit file export
and hit runnable jar file okay even
though we're going to be
converting into a runnable exe file
we still need it as a runnable jar file
for the moment so
runnable.jar file hit next um and let's
hit browse
and i'm just going to put it into our
episode 18.5 folder that i just made
specifically for this i actually went
ahead and made a folder for this uh for
this episode i'm
slowly improving the production value of
the series um
but uh let's just call it mine front
and you know shock required packages uh
required libraries into a generate jar
hit finish
okay and we can close the clips for now
so
once we go into our folder which of
course it opens on my other monitor
um you can see that yeah it's a winrar
archive we sort of if we double click on
it it might not work the clients might
be like dude
what's going on if they're if they're
noobs so um
and you'll have to go right click hit
open with the java platform
and it will work sure it'll work but hey
you know it's not gonna
it's not gonna be as cool as an as dot
exe
providing that your user is using
windows of course um
the benefit of this is that it runs mac
uh on windows and mac and with a bit of
working out linux as well um because i
think you might have to like use the
terminal and linux to get it to work um
but i'm not a linux person so i wouldn't
know that
um but yeah so uh basically let's go
ahead and
learn about how to how to convert this
so
go back to chrome because that's the web
browser i'm using
um we've got launch 4j okay this is a
cross-platform java executable wrapper
and um basically what it does is it is
it
uh it it converts you know your jar file
let me just open that again and why i
closed it um it converts your runnable
jar file
into a dot exe file and it's free it's
completely free it is
lightweight it's 26 kilobytes um and
it's it's awesome so
i'll put the link in the description
check it out hit download
and uh select your out of b on source
watch select the um
the dot exe so that you can install it
and uh once you
have downloaded it you can install it
and uh
let me just find where i downloaded it
here it is
run all right here it is okay so once
you've downloaded it just install it
i'm doing this in front of you guys
don't even know why i'm pretty sure you
guys are capable of installing something
run it um after you install it no splash
screen
and you get this nice um you get this
nice
uh sort of interface here so it's
wanting to
and you can see the the red star the red
star things are basically what's
required
so it's like if you're filling out a
form you know you have to fill out these
things so
let's uh let's browse so this is the
output file this is where you want the
dot exe to be let's just put it into
uh let's just go back to desktop
and episode 18.5 and
we'll call it minefront hit save and uh
at the end by the way put dot exe
um i don't know why it doesn't do that
automatically but it doesn't and that
causes problems
while it when it builds the actual file
okay so the other thing we need to
output is the jar file so the actual
sorry not the output we have to input
the jar file so what it's going to
convert
um so hit the folder thing and you can
see that i'm basically just selecting it
as a
episode 18.5 mindfront.jar hit open make
sure this is the executable file not
just the
jar file okay make sure it's a runnable
jar file because otherwise it won't find
the main method automatically
which will cause problems all right so
we've got these two things um the other
thing that you must do
is go into jie and specify the minimum
java runtime environment version i would
personally for this project recommend
1.4 i wouldn't
allow anyone to run this program that
has below 1.4 you could put it to 1.0.0
but uh just put to 1.4.0 we're currently
using 1.6
so everyone should have 1.6 if they
don't then this is like a
wake-up call for them to actually
install java properly so um
1.4 that's what i put all the time
anyway
um and the other thing we can specify is
the icon now this is kind of important
because if you don't put it you'll just
get a generic sort of
non like windows based icon where like
you don't specify an icon it gives you
like a default one
it doesn't look good so i've got this
nice channel emblem this is like my
youtube channel thing and it's actually
made out of text
um it's pretty cool it's the second
press stage uh emblem for modern warfare
2 but it's uh it's in text
you can't really see it at this
resolution but um
but hang on this is a since
since it's christmas i'll show you guys
here we go you can see that that's made
out of
well it's made out of text so that's
really cool um
but yeah so i've got this nice thing
i've just i've just down down
graded it down to 256 by 256
because that's the maximum resolution
for an icon on windows
so now is the dot png i just need to
convert it into a dot ico file
a dot ico file so there's a wonderful
website which i'll put in the
description as well called convert
ico.com okay convert ico.com
now all you have to do is basically
browse that file the
png file um well any probably any file
but i always go png anywhere
let's pan data icon yeah um make sure
it's a png file
select it hit open hit go and it
literally takes like five seconds
four three there we go okay and once
you've got it hit the download
button and it should
sorry for my uh coughing guys i'm still
a bit sick and it should download i
don't know where it's going to download
it to
um fantastic it's going to download it
into my download folder
um all right so
here it is i'll just copy it into here
and delete the old file
um so now we've got a dot icon file out
of it which we can actually use
um in in this program so
we've converted it into a dot ico file
now we just need to select it so here it
is dot ico
and that's it and we're done now all we
have to do is hit the
the build wrapper button and just it's
just a launch configuration file don't
worry about it i'm just going to put it
into the same folder as this
just name it mine front that's it hit
that and it should be done that's just
like a
xml file and as you can see it's
successfully completed
and now what we've got is a dot exe file
as you can see here i'm just going to
cut it
and put it onto the desktop so you guys
can see it it's a dot exe file as you
can see
um and it's got a nice icon and if you
if we open it it will actually run the
game
and it's a xa file and you can see that
frame rate wise we're actually getting a
higher frame rate than the runnable jar
so we're getting about 52 54 frames per
second
if we run the runnable jar we're
actually getting
quite a bit less we're getting like 38
frames per second so i guess that's one
advantage of actually doing this
you're not directly running it through
well you still are running it through
the virtual java thing but hey
look it's running well so um
so yeah that's basically how you um and
this icon of course is defined by the
actual java application
so it's that's why it's still like the
java coffee cup because um
that icon isn't defined by the xa thing
that we used it's actually defined by
the
and this one as well it's actually
defined by the by clips
so yeah but that's how you make your.exe
file out of your project guys merry
christmas
and uh yeah happy new year i guess i'm
probably not gonna make any more
episodes until
at least like january 5 or something i'm
gonna give myself a break
um but yeah merry christmas if you if
you're enjoying the series please leave
a like it helps a lot and i will see you
guys
next year 2012. goodbye
you